Alzheimer's disease is the most common
form of dementia estimated
five-and-a-half million Americans live
with the disease and that's about one in
10 adults aged 65 and older a new book
defines Alzheimer's as a spectrum
disorder the spectrum of hope and
optimistic and new approach to
Alzheimer's disease and other dementias
details as a plan to help patients live
more empowered and productive lives the
author is dr. Gayatri Devi and she joins
us at the table she's a neurologist at
New York's Lenox Hill Hospital and
director of New York memory and healthy
aging services welcome back thank you
good to see you I just say I think the
title of your book is great because
after you read it it does give you how
many people think once they're diagnosed
with Alzheimer's they're just going to
become a shell of themselves and you're
saying that is not true that's
absolutely untrue it's a myth
Alzheimer's is really a disease with
multiple different presentations
multiple different courses and different
people it's as individual as the person
who gets the illness and many of the
people with Alzheimer's live productive
functional lives in the community most
of them remain highly functioning you
say that's correct and give us numbers
on that
well basically 97% of patients with mild
Alzheimer's disease don't even get
diagnosed in their internist offices and
half of patients with moderate
Alzheimer's don't get diagnosed what
that means is that the percentage of
people that we think about when we think
about Alzheimer's the people in the
nursing home that's a very very small
fraction of the entirety of the people
who have the condition most people live
functional lives can be treated that's
another myth the treatment has no effect
and that's absolutely untrue I've worked
in this area for 23 years and treatment
does make a difference
patients do benefit from it it depends
on the individual patient
why are two-thirds of Alzheimer's
sufferers people living with Alzheimer's
women so women seem to have be at higher
risk for developing Alzheimer's even if
you account for the fact that they live
longer we're not really sure why that
might be maybe because they are not
succumbing to cardiovascular disease
like men are at an earlier point in
their lives also when there may be some
hormonal influences women also present
with differ
symptoms so it's important to realize
that women make their diagnosis may be
missed
they may be diagnosed as having anxiety
depression and unfortunately even
hysteria menopause symptoms can mimic
the symptoms of Alzheimer's so it's
important have Alzheimer's
genetics people often think that
genetics is the main determinant of
Alzheimer's and that's absolutely not
the case less than 5% of Alzheimer's
cases are from genetics the majority of
Alzheimer's can be prevented by
lifestyle changes and modifications
simple things like diet make sure that
you're eating a diet that's good for
your heart
I made a Turanian diet which is good for
your heart it's also a good anti
Alzheimer's diet make sure that you are
you know your lifestyle that you're
active
I exercise 30 minutes three times a week
you know and you do those things you're
unlikely to have Alzheimer's you can
prevent up to 60% of Alzheimer's cases
yes is there a test because I think
those old risk factors like high blood
pressure diabetes is there a test that
we could take or that we should take I
think a win so I think everybody over
the age of 50 just like we have baseline
colonoscopies baseline mammograms we
should all have a baseline brain
evaluation which includes a map of our
brain strengths and weaknesses so that
down the road if we forget all of us
forget and most forgetting is normal
then we're not going to get worried we
can actually look back and say look it's
a lot the same as it was ten years ago
nothing to worry about but if there's a
problem we can intervene earlier the
earlier we intervene the better the
better the yeah response to treatment I
really like the the title of your book
and about hope so can you reverse
Alzheimer's I I don't think we can
reverse it but we certainly can stop
progression we can certainly treat
effectively and many of my patients with
Alzheimer's are living in the community
functioning and enjoying their lives and
that's the purpose of this book is to
allow people to understand that there
are many myths about Alzheimer's there's
much stigma surrounding it
it's based on a fact that's not true
people think everyone with Alzheimer's
go into nursing homes and that is not
the case the majority stay in the
community so are you suggesting that
with respect to others that revealing
Alzheimer's may not be in the best
interest of the patient I generally tell
patients and families to be careful
about who to tell because you don't want
to be stigmatized and we're all human
beings we're social creatures we're
going to respond to how people treat us
so if people don't treat us as competent
beings which is sometimes what happens
when they hear the diagnosis Alzheimer's
you're going to respond in a more
different way
so I think it's important to be careful
who to tell and how you tell because
I've had patients get fired from their
jobs and they're just as good as someone
else who doesn't have the illness and
sometimes we better mmm
well dr. Gayatri Devi thank you so much
for this hopeful message we appreciate
it thanks for having me on the show the
spectrum of hope is on sale now